[Musique]
sigamary hobby
mes chers amis mes chers amis nous y
sommes et franchement la soirée est
longue mais ça fait du bien ça fait du
bien de se retrouver parce que ce moment
on l'a comment dire on l'a rêvé on a en
a eues on en a eu envie et je ne vois
pas plus beau symbole que finalement se
retrouver aujourd'hui pour notre
crémaillère d'une certaine manière à la
mutualité une énorme très mal hier mes
amis lyon est cru saint
la mutualité c'est cette solidarité
c'est le fait de bâtir ensemble c'est
finalement matière quelque chose qui est
plus grand que soi et c'est pour ça
sheitan effectivement l'un dans l'autre
le plus important c'est qu'on soit
ensemble et ce soir ce que nous faisons
c'est que nous bâtissons nous bâtissons
ce qui nous dépasse ce soir nous vivons
je prends un moment d'histoire ce soir
nous assumons une responsabilité et
cette responsabilité les communes c'est
de poser et tu l'a rappelé très cher
françois c'est de poser pour les
générations futures générations après
générations un grand courant un grand
courant du centre 7 qui dont tu parles
et qui sera à cet élément stabilisateur
cet arc central qui nous rassemble et
qui fera que pour les générations à
venir eh bien oui la france sera plus
forte
et d'amis
[Applaudissements]
savait mais serge jammy je ne serai pas
très longue je serais même très
succincte parce qu'à l'heure où les
dictionnaires intègre des nouveaux mots
je me suis dis très simplement que ce
serait intéressant de voir c'est quoi
notre maison commune du coup de prendre
quelques points pour la définir alors
même que et c'est pas nos opposants et
nos adversaires qui nous contrediront
qui passent leur temps à se définir soi
en débat soit en primaire je me suis dit
que ce serait plutôt important alors si
on devait revenir à cette définition de
ce grand courant ce qui est certain
c'est que ce n'est pas une fusion
acquisition le parti socialiste comme
les républicains nous l'ont des
conseillers on a vu dans quel état de
ruine ils sont aujourd'hui
ce grand courant mes amis c'est pas
comme ces boutiques vous connaissez ces
boutiques mono produits qu'ils vendent
un seul et unique produit ça europe
ecologie les verts a déjà essayé de
l'ehpad le phare et franchement c'est
une vraie galère
notre grand courant notre grand courant
mes amis c'est pas non plus l'objet ou
le joujou d'un homme hégémonique les
insoumis son assaut mise partout sauf
chez eux sauf dans leur propre parti
et enfin
enfin mes amis savaient ce grand courant
qu'est le nôtre c'est pas non plus un
héritage familial cm sur lequel il ya un
polémiste qui aurait eu envie d'avoir la
mainmise mais finalement qui s'y limiter
un doigt
et voulu faire un hold up
[Applaudissements]
parce que mes amis cette maison commune
elles portent notre centre elle porte la
droite elle porte la gauche parce que
mes amis depuis que le général de gaulle
a été là de tous les grands moments dans
les moments les plus importants de notre
histoire et les plus denses ensemble
citoyens abrite ce qu'on a de plus cher
ce qui nous unit ce qui nous rassemble
ce qui nous fait nous lever ce qui fait
qu'on est là aujourd'hui ensemble
citoyens c'est notre commun c'est notre
projet c'est un projet de démocratie et
de justice sociale pour la france ce
cher françois c'est notre projet pour un
projet de liberté et souveraineté
économique très cher edouard
c'est un projet
c'est un projet qui réunit notre vivre
ensemble et sa devise les la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité sans oublier la
laïcité très cher richard
parce que
parce que oui notre commun est de faire
france sur tous les territoires et pour
tous les citoyens
porter ce qui fait france c'est le
devoir d'un homme un seul le président
de la république et nous nous sommes à
ses côtés oui pour cinq ans de plus et
certains amis
il ya un vieux proverbe populaire et
africain qui dit que
c'est plus facile c'est plus rapide
d'aller très vite mais quand on est
ensemble on va certainement plus loin
alors ce soir que l'on soit de la
république en marche d'agir d'horizon
dans commun de territoire de progrès le
plus important c'est d'être ensemble
dans ce grand mouvement où nous en
sommes les vrais tueurs nés gamine
[Applaudissements]
ensemble citoyens c'est un espoir un
espoir pour nos enfants un espoir pour
s'être arc central qui centre désormais
dans la vie politique de notre pays
ensemble citoyen si cette envie de
france c'est cet héritage des lumières
c'est cet universalisme qu'ils soient
toujours porté plus fort plus haut c'est
enfin le courage de revendiquer la
raison comme boussole oui aujourd'hui il
ya de la démagogie oui aujourd'hui il ya
du populisme mais nous nous assumons
nous assumons ce courage de la raison
alors finalement ensemble citoyens c'est
se retrouver dans un grand mouvement
dans une grande association qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus beau mes amis que ça
cette raison
[Applaudissements]
cette maison elle est faite
pour être universel pour être ouverte
pour être inclusive et puis c'est la
maison de tous les citoyens la maison de
ceux qui veulent que la france soit plus
forte qu'elle soit plus unie et surtout
qu'elle réussisse pour chacun je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]